Evet canlarım selamlar. 3.
ünitemizdeyiz. Orta Çağ'daki siyasi ve
askeri gelişmeler kısmı bayağı bayağı
uzun. Bilmiyorum okulda henüz buraya
geçtiniz mi, işlediniz mi, bitirdiniz
mi? Ben iki video şeklinde bu kısmı
anlatacağım size. Sonra zaten genel
tekrar ve yazılı provalarıyla karşınızda
olacağım. Burayı güzelce dinleyin. Hemen
başlayalım. Bakın şimdi Orta Çağ'da
siyasi yapılar. Biz burada bu videoda
Çin İmparatorluğundan, Sasani
İmparatorluğu'ndan, Doğu Roma yani
Bizans İmparatorluğund'an 1. Göktürk,
Göktürk ve Uygur Devletinden
bahsedeceğiz. Kalan kısmı diğer videoda
işleyeceğiz. Bu Göktürkler çok ünlü bir
Türk devletidir. Orta Asya'da geniş
alanlara yayılmış bir devlet. Hemen
yanında Çin İmparatorluğu var. Doğu Roma
dediğimiz devlete bu topraklarda
belirmiş, yaşamış. Sınırlarını gerçekten
genişletmiş. İran topraklarında da
Sasanilerin medeniyeti görülüyor. Hemen
Çin İmparatorluğuyla başlayalım
canlarım. Canınızı sıkmasın. Hepsini
bilmek zorunda değilsiniz. Böyle uzun
gerçekten yorucu konular, bilgiler var
burada ama hepsini bilmek zorunda
değilsiniz. Benim anlattıklarıma dikkat
edin. Şimdi Çin İmparatorluğu deyince
evet kuruluş milattan önce 221 yılı,
milattan sonra 1912'ye kadar da
varlığını devam ettiriyor. Günümüzde de
Çin ne yapıyor? varlığını devam
ettiriyor. Kurucusu bak ismini devlete
veren kişi. Kurucusu Çin Shi Wandi. Bu
devletin imparatorluğun kurucusu kimmiş?
Çin Shi Wandi. Önemli bir isim. Zaten
kurulduğu bölgeyi biliyorsunuz. Çin
topraklarında kuruluyor. Burada başlıca
siyasi ve askeri gelişmeler diyor ya
arkadaşlar. En başta Çin topraklarında,
Çin İmparatorluğu'a feodal bir yapılanma
var. feodal yapılanma toprağa dayalı bir
sistemdir. Bir üretim mekanizmasını
ifade eder aynı zamanda. Aynı zamanda bu
dönemde Çin İmparatorluğunun ilk
zamanlarında bir sürü küçük devlet
varmış. İşte biz böyle olunca o devlette
siyasi birlik yok diyoruz. Siyasi
bütünlük sağlanamamış diyoruz. Ve bir
süre sonra bakıyoruz ki milattan önce
221 yılında Çin İmparatorluğu'nda siyasi
birlik ilk defa sağlanıyor. Daha sonra
farklı farklı hanedanlar, aileler
geliyor Çin İmparatorluğunu yönetiyor ve
220 yılında milattan sonra bak
kurulduktan yaklaşık 400 yıl sonra
merkezi otoriteleri kaybolmuş. Siyasi
yapılanmaları, birliktelikleri bozulmuş.
Sonra Sui hanedanlığı diye bir
hanedanlık yönetime gelmiş. Bak farklı
farklı aileler zaman ne yapıyorlar?
Yönetime geliyorlar. Bu su hanedanlığı
yıkıldıktan sonra evet beklediğimiz hale
geldi. Tank hanedanlığı. Bu Çin
İmparatorluğuna en güçlü dönemini
yaşatan aile tank hanedanlığı dönemi.
Buna özellikle dikkat çekmiş olalım.
Bakın imparatorluk altın çağını ne zaman
yaşamış? Tank hanedanlığı döneminde
yaşamış. Buna dikkat ediyorsunuz. Yine
bu imparatorluğun tank hanedanlığı
döneminde özellikle önemli bir imparator
var. Yani bu aileden gelip de ülkeyi en
iyi yöneten kişi imparator Chunzongmuş.
Bunu da bir duymuş oldunuz. Şimdi bu
tank hanedanlığı döneminde tarihte çok
önemli bir olay yaşanıyor. O da Talas
Savaşı. 751 yılında Müslüman Araplarla
yani Abbasilerle Karluk Türkleri
işbirliği yapıyor ve Çin'i Orta Asya'da
yenmeyi başarıyor. Bu çok önemli bir
gelişmedir. O zaman bu Talas Savaşı
dediğimiz savaş hangi hanedanlık
döneminde yaşanmış dersem ne diyorsunuz?
Tank hanedanlığı dönemi diyorsunuz.
Hemen bakalım yönetim yapısına. Çin
hükümdarı gök dinine göre göğün
yeryüzündeki temsilcisi ve göğün oğlu
olarak ifade ediliyor. Bakın burada bir
hükümdara kutsal bir karakter kimlik
kazandırılmış. Göğün oğlu demek ne
demek? Yani bir ilahi kaynaklı yönetim
modeli söz konusu. Hükümdar devletin
başı aynı zamanda halkın, milletin
efendisi olarak görülüyor. Yönetim
babadan oğula geçiyor ve veliat yani
tahta çıkacak olan kişi başkadının büyük
oğlu olarak belirleniyor. Bak yönetimde
bir aile var. Ailede tabii ki
imparatorun birden fazla eşi var ve
imparatorun gözdesi olan baş kadının
büyük oğlu ne yapıyormuş? İmparator
öldükten sonra tahta çıkıyormuş. Şimdi
Çin İmparatorluğu'nda en dikkat edilmesi
gereken nokta şudur. Antik dönemde yani
Çin'in eski dönemlerinde sınır
bölgelerinde kurulan valilik yönetim
sistemi var. Çinliler buna duhu zihudu
diyormuş. Buna dikkat edin. Sorularda
karşımıza gelirse Çin yönetim yapısında
duhu zihudu dediğim zaman neymiş?
Sınırlarda kurulan valilik yönetim
sistemiymiş. Buna dikkat edersiniz.
Bunun dışında canlarım anksi genel
valilik birimi bu nedir? Tank
hanedanlığı yani en güçlü dönemi yaşatan
aile döneminde batı topraklarını kontrol
altına almak, yönetimi kolaylaştırmak
amacıyla anksi genel valilik birimini
kurmuşlar. Demek ki biz burada neye
dikkat ettik? Belki de zorlanacağınız en
önemli noktalardan biri budur. Duhu
zihudu kavramı ve anksi genel valilik
birimi. Çin imparatorluğu deyince akılda
ne kalmalı? Tank hanedanlığı döneminde
en güçlü dönem yaşanmış. Talas Savaşı da
bu dönemde yaşanmış. Bakalım askeri
yapılarına. Bir kere Çin orduları çok
kalabalıktır. Tarih boyunca hep böyle
olmuş. Çünkü Çin'in nüfusu tarih boyunca
hep fazlaymış ve piyadelerden
oluşuyormuş. Piyade dediğimiz yürüyen
askerler. Ama tabii sınır bölgelerinde
Türkler olduğu için ve Türkler atı çok
iyi kullandığı için Çinliler ne
yapmışlar? Türklerle mücadele edebilmek
amacıyla hafif süvari birliklerini yani
atlı birliklerini oluşturmuşlar ve
faaliyetlerini yürütmüşler. Bunun
dışında canlarım tank hanedanlığı
sınırlarını batıya genişletmek amacıyla
askeri tarım toplulukları olan Tuntian
sistemini kurmuşlar. Bölgede tarım
faaliyetleri başlatmış ve bu yolla hem
askerlerin gıda sorununu çözmüşler hem
de bölgede Han ulusu kültürünün baskın
olmasını sağlamışlar. Demek ki canlarım
burada Tuntian sistemine dikkat etmek
lazım. Bu Tuntian sistemi doğrultusunda
tarım faaliyetleri yapmışlar. Bu da
önemli bir kavram. Gelelim İran
topraklarındaki Sasanhanilere. 22651
yılları arasında yaşamış bir
imparatorluktur. Gerçekten de dönemine
damga vurmuş devletlerden,
imparatorluklardan bir tanesidir.
Kurucusu Erdeşir adında bir kral, bir
yöneticidir. İran topraklarında kurulmuş
bir medeniyettir. Sasaniler yaşadığı
dönem ki Orta Çağ'da yaşıyorlar. Bakalım
sınır komşuları. Akun Devleti denilen
bir Türk devleti, Doğu Roma
İmparatorluğu ve İslam devleti. Yani
Sasanilerin varlığı İslamiyet'in yayılma
dönemlerine denk geliyor. İslamiyet'in
böyle yeryüzüne yeni indiği, yayılmaya
başladığı dönemlerde Sasaniler varmış.
Hatta Sasanilerin varlığına da Hz. Ömer
döneminde son verilecek Nihavent
savaşıyla. Buna da dikkat çekmiş olalım.
Şimdi Orta Asya'da canlılarım Göktürkler
çok güçlü bir devletti. İran
topraklarında Sasaniler de çok güçlüydü.
Ve o dönemde İpek Yolu güzergahında
Akhun Devleti çok güçlenmiş ve
Göktürkler ne yapmışlar? Sasanilerle
işbirliği yapmışlar. Akun devletini
yıkmışlar. Ama daha sonra da İpek
Yolunda Sasanilerin güçlendiği
görülüyor. Ve Göktürkler bu sefer de ne
yapıyor? Sasanilere karşı Doğu Roma'yla
işbirliği yapıyor ve Sasaniler bu
süreçte yenilgiye uğratılıyor. Sasaniler
deyince aklımıza antik dönemlerde eski
çağ medeniyetlerinden Persler gelmeli.
Çünkü İran topraklarında eskiden Persler
vardı ve Perslerin yönetim anlayışı
yapısı Sasanilere ne yapıyor? Yansıyor.
Çünkü aynı bölgede kurulduğu için bir
kültür birlikteliği, kültür etkileşimi
yaşanıyor. Sasaniler aynı Persiler gibi
böyle sınırlarını genişletmek isteyen
bir imparatorluk. Bu yüzden de ne
yapacak? Doğu Roma İmparatorluğuyla
yüzyıllar boyu süren savaşlar yapılacak.
Bu açıdan önemlidir. Yönetim yapısına
baktığımız zaman hükümdarlar yani Sasani
liderleri Şahan Şah yani şahların şahı
unvanını kullanıyor. Danışma kurulları
var. Yani Şahan Şahların yanında yönetim
anlayışını kolaylaştırmak amacıyla
danışma kurulu kurmuşlar ve kararlar bu
danışma kurulu çerçevesinde görüşülerek
alınmaya çalışılmış. merkeziyetçi bir
yönetim anlayışına sahipler. Din
adamlarının yönetimde etkisinin olduğunu
görüyoruz. Yani din adamları hükümdar
üzerinde etkili olabiliyor. Bu açıdan
önemli. Devlet işleri divan adı verilen
mecliste yani kurulda yürütülüyor. Ülke
dört ana eyalete, satraplıklara
bölünüyor. Bakın bu satraplıklar,
eyaletler de valiler tarafından
yönetiliyor. Zaten bu satraplık kelimesi
Perslerden gelmedir. Persler de böyle
sınırları genişleyince yönetimi
kolaylaştırmak için ne yapmışlar? Ülkeyi
idari birimlere bölmüşler. Bak
Sasanilerde de aynı mantık devam etmiş.
Ve bu idari birimler de kimler
tarafından yönetiliyor? Valiler
tarafından yönetiliyor. Askeri yapıya
baktığımız zaman Sasani
İmparatorluğu'nda ordu süvarilerden yani
Atlas yerlerden ve piyadelerden
oluşuyor. Süvariler tabii ki piyadelere
göre daha üstündür. Hızlıdır, güçlüdür.
Manevra kabiliyeti yüksektir. Atlı
askerler her zaman Orta Çağ'da daha
değerli görülmüştür. Aklınızda olsun.
Zırh teknolojisinde ileriydiler.
Romalılar tarafından örnek alınırdı.
Zırh teknolojisinde yani askerlerin
giyimlerinde, kuşamlarında,
elbiselerindeki zırhlar savaşa çok
uygundur ve o dönemde Sasani zırhları
ünlüymüş. Ordu birlikleri onlu sisteme
göre düzenlenmiş. Tabii ki düzenlensin.
Çünkü onlu sistemi dünyada Türkler
düzenledi. Özellikle Asya Hunları
döneminde ve tüm dünya bu 10lu sistem
anlayışından etkilendi. Neydi onlu
sistem? Orduyu onlu, yüzlü, binli,
10.000 şeklinde örgütlemekti. E Asya
Hunlarında görülen bir sistemdi. Diğer
medeniyetlerde ne yapmışlar? Bu
sistemden etkilenmişler. Orduya
baktığımız zaman farklı farklı etnik
gruplardan oluşuyordu. Askerlerin bir
kısmı maaş alıyor veya ikta olarak yani
tarım toprakları üzerinden gelir elde
ediyordu. Yani hem maaş alanlar var hem
de iktidar topraklarından gelir elde
edenler varmış. savaşlarda filleri
kullanmışlar ve genel olarak baktığımız
zaman Sasanilerde ok, yay, mızrak,
kılıç, kalkan, gürz, zırh ya da miifer
gibi savaş aletleri görülüyor. Miifer
dediğimiz de o başa takılan savaş
başlıklarıydı. Görüyorsunuz canlarım,
Sasanilerin kurulduğu bölge İran
topraklarında sınırlarını çok
genişletmişler. Doğu Roma'yla sınırlar
ve Göktürklerle sınırlar. Unutmayın,
Göktürklerle Sasaniler işbirliği yapmış.
Hangi devleti yıkmış? Akunları. Daha
sonra Sasaniler güçlenince de Doğu Roma
ile Göktürkler işbirliği yapmış ve
Sasanileri İpek Yolu güzergahında
yenmeyi başarmışlar. Gelelim Doğu Roma
İmparatorluğuna. Bir kere kurucusu 1.
Konstantin kurulduğu bölge İstanbul ve
başlayacağız siyasi askeri gelişmelere
baktığımız zaman asla unutmayın Margos
ve Anatolios anlaşmalarıyla Avrupa
Hunları tarafından Doğu Roma vergiye
bağlanıyor. 1. Jüyanus önemli
hükümdarlardan yani imparatorlardan
biridir. Bu dönemlerde sınırlar
genişletilmiş. Kuzey Afrika ve İtalya
ele geçirilmiş. Heraklios dönemi çok
önemli. Çünkü bu dönemde atık Sasaniler
çok güçlüydü ve Anadolu topraklarına
ulaşmıştı. İran'dan Anadolu'ya
sıçramışlardı. Ve Heraklios ne yapıyor?
Sasanileri Anadolu topraklarından atmayı
başarıyor. Suriye, Filistin, Mısır
toprakları özellikle söylüyorum bu
dönemde geri alınıyor ve sınırlar bayağı
bayağı genişletiliyor. Bakın Suriye
dediğimiz yer neresi? Bu topraklar.
Mısır dediğimiz yer neresi dersem
burası. Yani Doğu Roma'nın sınırlarını
bayağı bayağı genişletmişler. Filistin
neredeydi? Onu da gösterelim. Filistin
de tam olarak buradaymış. Aklınızda
olsun. Peki Doğu Roma dediğimiz devlet
ne zaman son bulacak? 1453 tarihinde
İstanbul Mehmet zamanında Osmanlı
padişahı Fatih Sultan Mehmet ne yapacak?
Doğu Roma İmparatorluğuu yıkacak. Yani
Bizans İmparatorluğu tarih sahnesine
karışmış olacak. Hatta ı Mehmet Fatih
unvanını alacak. Yönetim yapısına
baktığımız zaman Bizans yani Doğu Roma
imparatorları dünyevi ve ilahi otoriteyi
birleştirmişler. Otokratik bir yönetici
konumunda bulunmuşlar. İmparator baş
kanun koyucu. En yüksek yargıç hem idari
hem mali hem de askeri otorite. Bu
açıdan baktığımız zaman imparatorun Doğu
Roma imparatorlarının mutlak gücü elinde
bulundurduğunu görüyoruz. Ama buna
rağmen Orta Çağ Avrupa'sında kilisenin
etkisi her zaman görülüyor. Kilise
özellikle Katolik kilisesi yönetim
anlayışında bazı dönemlerde etkin
olabiliyor. Bu açıdan önemli. Yönetimde
yüksek memurlar tarafından ve asiller,
soylular tarafından oluşturulan bir
senato vardır. Senato yönetimde
imparatorun yanında etkin bir organdır.
Büyük domestik adı verilen makam
özellikle başbakanlık görevini
yürütmüştür. Eyaletlerin başında tekfur
adı verilen valiler bulunur. Bizans
dediğimiz zaman zaten akla gelen en
önemli kavramlardan biri tekfur
kelimesidir. Ve bizans'ın topraklarını
yöneten valiler tekfur ismiyle anılıyor.
Buna dikkat edersiniz. Askeri yapıya
baktığımız zaman adlı birimlerin
önemsendiğini görüyoruz. Sasani
İmparatorluğu'nun etkisiyle Bizans
İmparatorluğu'nda temalar ve tagmalar
olmak üzere iki ana askeri yapı var.
Burada dikkat etmeniz gereken önemli bir
nokta var. Tema dediğimiz zaman ya da
temalar dediğimiz zaman eyaletlerdeki
toprağa bağlı köylü milislerden
oluşurken tagmalar dediğimiz zaman
başkentteki profesyonel askerler
aklımıza gelecek. Tekrar söyleyeyim
temalar eyaletlerde toprağa bağlı köylü
milislerden oluşuyor. Yani düzensiz
askeri birimlerden oluşuyor. Ama tagma
deyince başkentte profesyonel birimler
aklımıza gelsin. Demek ki iki ana unsur
var ordu yapısında. Tema sistemi idari
ve askeri gücü birleştiren bir yapı olup
tema komutanları imparator tarafından
atanıyor. Şimdi bir görevlinin imparator
tarafından atanıyor olması o devletin
merkezi yapısını güçlü tutmak
istemesiyile alakalı olduğuna dikkat
edersiniz. Gelelim gelelim haritamıza.
Doğu Roma'nın bulunduğu bölge burası.
Dediğim gibi Sasaniler Doğu Roma'yla
sınır. Avrupa Hunları o dönemde Doğu
Roma'yı ne yapmış? Margos, Anatolios
anlaşmalarıyla vergiye bağlamış. Batı
Roma dediğimizde zaten batı tarafta
bulunan Roma'ydı. Merkezi İtalya'ydı.
Gelelim 1. Göktürk Devletine. 552
yılında kurulmuş, 630 yılında yıkılmış.
Kurucusu Mumin Kaan'dır. Ama devleti en
güçlü dönemini yaşatan lider Muka
Kaan'dır. Buna öncelikle dikkat etmek
lazım. Kurulduğu bölge neresi? Türkistan
yani Orta Asya topraklarında özellikle
Türklerin kutsal saydığı Ötüken,
Göktürklerin kurulduğu yerdir. Bu
minkaan döneminde ülke ikili bir yönetim
anlayışıyla yönetiliyor. Yani doğu, batı
şeklinde yönetiliyor. Doğu tarafını asıl
merkezi, asıl hükümdar yani bu minkaanı
yönetirken devletin batı kanadını istemi
yavgı ne yapıyor? Yönetiyor. Biraz önce
bahsetmiştim ya. Göktürkler ne
yapmışlar? Sasanilerle işbirliği
yapmışlar ve Akunları yenmişler,
yıkmışlar. Ya işte istemi yavgı
döneminde ne olmuş? Sasanilerle ittifak
kurulmuş. Daha sonra da zaten Göktürkler
gitmişler Sasanileri yenmek için Doğu
Roma'yla işbirliği yapmışlar. Bu açıdan
çok önemli. Çünkü ilk defa Doğu Roma
İmparatorluğu üzerine elçi gönderen
istemi Yabgu yani Göktürk Devleti olmuş.
Mukan Kaan en güçlü dönemi yaşatmıştı
ama Mukan Kaan gittikten sonra Taspar
Kaan yönetimine geliyor. Taspar Kaan'da
öldükten sonra zaten devlet dikiş
tutmayacak. Özellikle söylüyorum. Çin
entrikaları göktürklerin yıkılmasına,
Çin'in boyunduruğunun altına girmesine
sebep olacak. Bu açıdan çok çok önemli.
Hatta bir 50 yıl kadar Çin esaret dönemi
denilen bir dönem yaşanıyor. Göktürkler
Çinlilerden kurtulmak için birçok isyan
çıkartıyorlar. Kürşat isyanı da tarihte
çok ünlüdür. Bu isyanların öncüsü Kürşat
isyanıdır. Yönetim yapısına geldiğimiz
zaman devletin başında Kaan yani
hükümdar bulunuyor. Kaan devletin tabii
ki mutlak gücüydü. Kut anlayışı
doğrultusunda Kaan meşruiyetini
sağlıyordu. Ne demek? Kut Tanrı
tarafından verildiğine inanılan devlet
yönetimi yetkisine biz KT diyoruz. Demek
ki Türklerde hükümdarlar devlet yönetimi
yetkisini tanrıdan alıyor. Böyle
inanılıyor. Bu da hükümdarın, ka'ın
mutlak gücünü ne yapıyor? Arttırıyor. Bu
açıdan önemli. Devlet işlerinin
görüşüldüğü ve kararların danışıldığı
bir meclis vardır. O meclise de
Türklerde kurultay deniliyor. Kaan
kurultayın başkanıdır. Yani kurultay
meclis toplanacağı zaman kimin kararıyla
toplanıyor dersem tabii ki Kaan istiyor.
Kurultay toplanıyor ve kurultayın
başkanlığını yine Kaan yapıyor. Buna
dikkat edersiniz. Askeri yapıya bakalım.
Göktürk ordusunun temelinde tabii ki
atlı süvari birlikleri vardır. Sebebi
ise hızlı hareket etme isteği. Çin'in
kalabalık nüfusu ordusuyla mücadele
edebilmek istiyorsan hızlı dinamik
olmalısın ve özellikle geleneksel
anlamda Turan taktiğini uygulamalısın.
Turan taktiği Türklerin geleneksel savaş
yöntemiydi. Bütün halk savaş çıkarsa
eğer gerçekten ciddi bir savaş varsa
ortada kadın, çoluk, çocuk, yaşlı fark
etmez. Herkes asker sayılır ve dediğim
gibi kadınlar da savaşçıdır, çocuklar da
savaşçıdır. Biz buna zaten ordu millet
anlayışı diyoruz. Orduda disiplinli bir
yapı var. Zaten Asya Hullarından süre
gelen onlu sistem kullanılmaya devam
ediliyor. Ok, yay, kılıç gibi silahlar
etkin bir biçimde kullanılıyor.
Özellikle okay Türklerin savaş aracı
olarak sürekli kullandıkları aletlerdir.
Gelelim ik Göktürk Devletine bakalım.
Şimdi kurucusu Kutluk Kaan zaten Çin
esaretinden Türkleri topladığı için,
derleyip toparladığı için ilteriş
unvanını alıyor Kutluk Kaan ve Göktürk
Devleti'ni kuruyor. İşte Kutluk Kaan'dan
dolayı Göktürk Devleti'nin diğer bir
ismi Kutluk Devleti olarak tarihe
geçmiş. Buna dikkat edersiniz. Şimdi
gelelim başlıca siyasi ve askeri
gelişmelere. Arkadaşlar 50 yıl boyunca
Çin esareti yaşandı. 1. Göktürkler Çin
esaretinden kurtulmak istedi, mücadele
etti. Ama en sonunda Kutluk Kaan geldi.
Göktürkleri kurtardı. Bağımsızlığını
ilan etti. Ötüken de ik Göktürk
Devletini kurdu. Bakın Kutluk Kaan
kurduğu için Göktürk Devleti'ne ne
diyormuşuz biz aynı zamanda? Kutluk
Devleti diyormuşuz. Buna dikkat
edersiniz. Peki Kutluk Kaan hangi unvanı
kullanmış? İlteriş yani derleyen,
toparlayan anlamına gelen bu unvanı
kullanıyor. Tony Yukuk denilen bir vezir
var. Çok önemli. Hem bu dönemlerde hem
de ilerleyen süreçte Bilge Kaan
döneminde devletin önemli bir veziridir.
Devletin özellikle iyi yönetilmesinde ve
en güçlü dönemlere ulaşmasında vezir
Tonyuk'un faaliyetleri etkili olmuştur.
Buna özellikle dikkat çekmiş oldum.
Kutluk Kan ve Tonyuk liderliğinde ik
Göktürk Devleti her fırsatta Çin
İmparatorluğu üzerine akınlar
düzenliyor. Çünkü bir kere Türkler
süvari birliklerden oluştuğu için
dinamik ve hızlı olduğu için vurkaç
yöntemiyle Çin'i sürekli rahatsız
ediyor. İpek yolunda Çin'le mücadele
halindeyiz. Kapkan Kaan diye bir lider
var. O geldiği zaman Türkistan'daki tüm
Türk boyları tek çatı altında
toplanıyor. Bakın Türkleri bir araya
getirmek, siyasi birliği sağlamak
anlamına geliyor. Ve Orta Asya'da siyasi
birliği sağlayan bir sürü Türk devleti
vardır. Mesela Asya Hunları, 1.
Göktürkler, Göktürkler, Uygurlar.
Bunların hepsi de Orta Asya'da yaşayan
Türkleri tek bayrak altında toplamayı
başarmıştır. Ve biz buna ne diyoruz?
Siyasi birliği sağlamak diyoruz. Buna
dikkat edersiniz. Bilge Kaan dediğimiz
zaman devletin en güçlü dönemi akla
gelecek ve Bilge Kaan yönetimde
özellikle kardeşi Kültigin ve veziri
Tony Yukupla yönetimde çok etkili
olacak. En güçlü dönem Bilge Kaan
zamanında yaşanacak. Daha sonra zaten
Bilge Kaan öldükten sonra Göktürkler
zayıflayacak. Bir süre sonra Karluk
Türkleri, Basmil ve Uygurlar
toplanacaklar. Göktürk Devleti'nin
varlığına son verecekler. Bu sefer de
hangi dönem başlayacak? Uygur Devleti
dönemi. Gelelim Uygurlara. Bir kere
kurucusu Kutluk Bilgekül Kaan. Devletin
kurulduğu topraklar tabii ki Orta Asya
yani Türkistan bölgesi. Türkistan'da
merkez ötükenmiş. Daha sonrasında
başkent yani merkez Karabalgasum kentine
taşınmış. Devlet en güçlü dönemini Moyen
Çur zamanında yaşamış ve Uygurların
özellikle Çin imparatorluğuyla çok iyi
ilişkiler kurduğunu, e, çok aktif bir
ticaret yaptığını biliyoruz. Bakın Çin
İmparatorluğuna en güçlü dönemini
yaşatan tank hanedanlığı döneminde
Uygurlarla ne yapmış? Çinliler işbirliği
içerisine girmişler. Büyük diye bir
hükümdarları var. Çok önemli. Büyük
döneminde Uygur Devleti'nde monei inancı
benimseniyor. Moneizm inancı
benimsendikten sonra Uygur
hükümdarlarında unvan değişikliği bile
oluyor. Ay ve Kün unvanını
kullanıyorlar. Demek ki money inancının
benimsenmesi hükümdarların unvanlarına
bile etkide bulunmuş. Ve bu dönemde
özellikle Uygurlar et yemekten
savaşmaktan uzaklaşmışlar. Çünkü
maniheizm inancı et yemeği savaşmayı
yasaklıyor. Doğru bulmuyor. Bu yüzden
Uygurların yönetim anlayışı ve hayata
bakışları bu inançtan doğrudan
etkilenmişler. Bir süre sonra Orta
Asya'da Kırgızlar güçlenecek ve Uygur
devletiin varlığı sona erecek. Ama
Uygurlar bir şekilde varlıklarını
yüzyıllarca sürdürmeyi başarmışlar.
Özellikle Çin'in kuzeyinde sarı yani
Kanu Uygurları ve diğeri ise daha önemli
Beş Balık, Turfan, Hoça, Kaşkar gibi
önemli Türkistan topraklarındaki önemli
Türk bölgelerinde Turfan Uygur Devleti
varlığını devam ettiriyor. Günümüzde
Doğu Türkistan'da işte Çin'in baskısına
maruz kalan, Çin'in asimile
politikalarına maruz kalan devlet
günümüzde işte Turfan Uygurları Sincan
Uygur Özerk bölgesinde varlıklarını
devam ettirmeye çalışıyorlar. hala
direniyorlar. Aklınızda olsun. Yönetim
yapısına geldiğimiz zaman evet monei
inancı benimsenirse Uygurlarda ne olur?
Yönetim anlayışı değişir. Yine
Göktürklerde olduğu gibi yönetimde
kurultay adı verilen meclis vardı.
Karabalgosun bunların merkeziydi ve
devlet meclisi burada merkezde
toplanırdı. Askeri yapıya baktığımız
zaman Göktürklerde neyse Uygurlarda da
oydu. Atlı birlikler önemseniyordu ama
dediğim gibi Mani inancının
benimsenmesiyle Uygurlardaki askeri yapı
zayıfladı. Çünkü savaşmak yasak kabul
edilmişti. Bu da Uygurlara olumsuz bir
sonuç getirdi. Canlarım bu derste
söyleyeceklerim bu kadar. Bir dahaki
derste İslam medeniyetine yani Hazreti
Muhammed dönemine geçeceğiz. Oradan
devam edeceğiz. Daha sonra genel tekrar
ve yazılı provasıyla karşınızda
olacağım. Seviliyorsunuz. İyi
çalışmalar. Kendinize iyi bakın.